Приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13.
Для нашей работы с антифрод-системами очень часто нам необходимы чекеры.
Ну, точнее, в них необходимости нет практически никакой, но людям, видимо, так спокойнее работать.
Я не рекомендую использовать публичные чекеры, множество раз уже говорил, поэтому не буду сейчас повторять,
что все публичные чекеры являются ханепотами.
Как же в таком случае быть, когда хочется проверить свою информацию, хочется проверить, например, свой прокси,
но Вектор сказал, что чекерами пользоваться нельзя.
Наверное, нужно купить доступ в антифрод-систему, самый простой вариант.
И вот у нас есть IP Quality Score, великолепная антифрод-система, я сотрудничаю с ней уже множество лет.
И сейчас я покажу вам, как получить эту антифрод-систему.
В ее максимальной комплектации, абсолютно бесплатно.
Хотите? Тогда смотрите.
Итак, система IP Quality Score, ее основное предназначение, ее первое основное предназначение, это проверка IP-адреса.
Они проверяют IP-адрес множеством различных путей, они позволяют также проверить кредитные карты,
они позволяют проверить номера телефонов и так далее.
Но с чем мы будем с вами работать сейчас?
Конечно же, вы подумаете.
Вы думали, что я дам вам ссылку на бесплатный тест.
На самом деле, пользователи часто балуются этим тестом, и я всегда с ними ругаюсь по этому поводу.
Потому что этот тест, это полное говнище, из всего которого можно только найти в интернете.
Я объясню вам почему.
Если мы перейдем с вами на Plans and Pricing данного веб-ресурса, то мы увидим, что у нас, вот он наш бесплатный чек.
Вот он, вот, пожалуйста.
Вы можете зарегистрироваться здесь.
И получить себе ту же самую страницу для чека абсолютно бесплатно.
И можете проверять, сколько тысяч IP-адресов можете проверять в месяц, можете проверять имейл и так далее.
Но дело в том, что здесь, если мы сравним с вами базовый тип и тип стартап, мы увидим разницу только в запросах.
Самая магия, начальная магия начинается с типа SMB Basic.
Потому что здесь у нас есть премиум-блэк-листы.
Расширенные блэк-листы.
Это уже увеличивает возможность анализа нашего IP-адреса.
И тот IP-адрес, который на типе Free будет показан, например, как абсолютно чистый, на типе SMB Basic будет показан уже как грязный.
Вполне возможно, если он такой и есть.
Потому что подключаются дополнительные источники информации.
На SMB Plus используется даже проверка на предмет резидентных.
Прокси.
Отличный, на самом деле, отличный сервис, даже на этом относительно дешевом типе.
Но, конечно же, Enterprise это самое лучшее, что может быть.
Fraud Fusion.
Великолепная система, которая покажет даже историю IP-адреса.
Abus Shield.
Прекрасно.
Dark Data.
Возможность получить данные с различных прокси-сервисов.
С ботнетов, когда используется прокси.
Кстати, вот здесь это Merging Botnets.
Великолепно.
Великолепнейшим образом раньше реагировал на прокси Luxox, 911 и так далее.
Иными словами, вот этот тип самый лучший, но цена его начинается от 5000 долларов в месяц.
Вы можете, кстати, получить доступ в него на сайте DetectExpert.
У нас в чекерах подключен именно этот тип.
Но я хочу предложить вам еще одну альтернативу.
Как вы можете получить этот чекер, например, без необходимости логиниться на сайт DetectExpert.
Переходим в Google и вводим Indeed.
Вот такой вот веб-ресурс.
Данный веб-ресурс позволяет производить поиски работы и так далее.
Нам он фактически сейчас как таковой, как его основной функционал не нужен.
Нам нужно на этом ресурсе немного паразитировать.
Нажимаем клавишу F12.
Переходим на вкладку Network.
Обновляем страницу.
Убираем. У меня фильтр стоит здесь на Image.
Делаем All.
И убираем здесь третисторонние ресурсы.
Итак, мы получили вот такой вот вагон информации.
Нам нужно из этой информации найти кое-что, что нас интересует.
В частности, давайте посмотрим сейчас на веб-ресурсы,
которые загружаются.
Давайте сейчас сделаем по-другому.
Давайте уберем весь лог и зайдем на Singin.
Здесь нам вполне возможно будет немного проще.
И вот, вот запрос, о котором я хотел вам сказать.
На странице Singin нам нужно отхватить вот такой вот запросик Fetch.
Кстати, он у нас пришел откуда?
Это третисторонний ресурс? Да.
Можете включить здесь фильтрацию третисторонних ресурсов.
И вы увидите вот этот запрос.
Чем он нам важен?
Двойной клик на этом запросе, и мы получаем доступ к IP Quality Score CDN.
Пожалуйста, я вводю информацию о моем девайсе.
В данном случае сюда подключен максимальный тариф, тариф Enterprise.
То есть, вы можете увидеть здесь, сколько система IP Quality Score считает,
что вы используете.
То есть, fraud, например.
Прокси, VPN, TOR.
Какая страна у вас.
Ну и, соответственно, все, что вы захотите о вашем IP-адресе.
Немного здесь используется даже и проверка железа.
Ну, самый основной параметр, который нас интересует, это fraud chance.
Это действительно важный параметр.
Ну и Device ID, как идентификатор девайса, чтобы вы можете, например, откалибровать свой антидетект.
Видит он вас как новое лицо, либо же видит он вас как уже известное ему лицо.
Ну, также можно обратить внимание на SSL-отпечаток, как один из вариантов.
Данное отверстие в системе безопасности веб-ресурса Indeed существует уже довольно давно.
Я его обнаружил совершенно случайно, когда один из пользователей пришел и сообщил,
что у него проблемы с веб-сайтом Indeed на моей сборке антидетекта.
И когда мы зашли на этот веб-ресурс, я, соответственно, с помощью анализа исходного кода,
увидел, что здесь используется система IP Quality Score.
И, соответственно, мы поняли, что у него проблема из-за использования некачественных прокси.
Хотя пользователь также сделал интересное наблюдение,
что если использовать macOS, то вот здесь вот fraud chance падает.
Так что тоже можно проверить.
Можете обратить на это внимание.
Ссылка может быть статичной.
Я могу, в принципе, предоставить ее вам вот в таком вот виде, если вы захотите скопировать.
Но я рекомендую все-таки перейти на сайт Indeed и найти данную ссылку самостоятельно.
И, забегая вперед, хочу сказать, что Indeed далеко не один ресурс,
который использует такую методику, скажем так.
И для тех, кто знаком, что существует такой процесс,
который называется Google Дорки,
то благодаря Google Доркам можно еще поискать другие веб-ресурсы,
которые дают доступ напрямую в систему IP Quality Score.
И, возможно, даже вы найдете еще и систему Threat Matrix,
если правильно подойдете к поиску Дорков из предыдущего урока
по анализу антифрод-систем для новичков.
Так что пользуйтесь максимальным тарифом,
который любезно предоставила нам Google Дорки.
Это компания Indeed.
Чекер отличный.
И я надеюсь, что он будет работать долго и на нашу пользу.
Спасибо за внимание.
С вами был Вектор Т13.